"AC 360" BEGINS NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING.
IT WAS BILLED AS AN EXAMINATION
OF THE PRESSURE PUT ON THEN VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE TO DO
DONALD TRUMP'S BIDDING.
AND TODAY HIS TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE JANUARY 6th HEARINGS
CERTAINLY WAS THAT.
BUT IN A LARGER SENSE, IT WAS
ALSO A REVELATION OF HOW
THOROUGHLY THOSE WHO WERE
PUSHING TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING WAS
LEGALLY AND CONSTITUTIONALLY
DUBIOUS AND POTENTIALLY A CRIME.
THEY KNEW, BUT ACCORDING TO THE
TESTIMONY WE HEARD TODAY, THEY
DID IT ANYWAY.
AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT NOT
ONLY KNEW THAT ACCORDING TO THE
TESTIMONY, HE ALSO KNEW IN REAL
TIME THAT THE ACTIONS HE'D BEEN
TAKING AND WAS ABOUT TO TAKE
WITH HIS 2:24 P.M. TWEET
CONDEMNING MIKE PENCE DIRECTLY
ENDANGERED HIS VICE PRESIDENT'S
LIFE.
HE'D BEEN TOLD EXACTLY HOW BAD
IT WAS AT THE CAPITOL.
>> ALTHOUGH THE PRESIDENT'S
CHIEF OF STAFF, MARK MEADOWS,
HAS REFUSED TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE, MR. MEADOWS'
AID, BEN WILLIAMSON AND WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
MATTHEWS TESTIFIED THAT
MR. MEADOWS WENT TO THE DINING
NEAR THE OVAL OFFICE TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THE VIOLENCE AT
THE CAPITOL BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT'S 2:24 P.M. TWEET.
>> IT WAS CLEAR THAT IT WAS
ESCALATING AND ESCALATING
QUICKLY.
SO, THEN WHEN THAT TWEET, THE
MIKE PENCE TWEET, WAS SENT OUT,
I REMEMBER US SAYING THAT THAT
WAS THE LAST THING THAT NEEDED
TO BE TWEETED AT THAT MOMENT.
>> CONGRESSMAN PETE AVRIL SAYS
THE COMMITTEE'S INVESTIGATION
SAYS THAT IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT
TWEET, THE CROWD INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE THE CAPITOL SURGES.
TWO MINUTES LATER, THE SECRET
SERVICE EVACUATED THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT FROM THE SENATE
CHAMBER, COMING WITHIN 40 FEET,
ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION OF THE ANGRY MOB.
NOW, THE COMMITTEE PUT OUT NEW
IMAGES TODAY OF THE LOCATION
THAT PENCE WAS LATER TAKEN TO, A
LOADING DOCK, BY THE LOOKS OF
IT, WHERE HE WAS FORCED TO
SHELTER UNTIL CONTROL OF THE
CAPITOL WAS RESTORED.
THE PHOTOS WERE NEW AND SO WAS
THE TESTIMONY THAT KNOWING WHAT
HE KNEW, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
STILL SENT OUT A TWEET THAT
FORMER WHITE HOUSE DEPUTY PRESS
SECRETARY SARA MATTHEWS
TESTIFIED WAS, QUOTE, LIKE HE
WAS POURING GASOLINE ON THE
FIRE.
WHICH GETS TO THE KIND LG FOR
IT, THE LEGAL THEORY TOUTED BY
JOHN EASTMAN, SEEN HERE WHIPPING
UP THE CROWD AT THE JANUARY 6th
RALLY THAT DAY.
HE ARGUED THAT VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE THAT DAY COULD REJECT
ELECTORAL VOTES THAT TRUMP WAS
CHALLENGING.
THIS IS WHAT HE MOSTLY TOLD THE
PANEL.
>> I ASSERT MY FIFTH AMENDMENT
RIGHT AGAINST BEING COMPELLED TO
BE A WITNESS AGAINST
FIFTH.
>> ACCORDING TO PETE AVEOLAR, HE
TOOK THE FIFTH -- TIMES.
>> THERE WAS NO BASIS IN THE
CONSTITUTION OR LAWS OF THE
UNITED STATES AT ALL FOR THE
THEORY ESPOUSED BY MR. EASTMAN.
AT ALL.
NONE.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE TOLD MIKE
PENCE, WHOSE OWN LEGAL STAFF
ALSO RESEARCHED THE QUESTION,
ALSO FOUND EASTMAN'S THEORY
BOGUS AND -- GET THIS -- TOLD
EASTMAN SO DIRECTLY.
>> THE HISTORY WAS ABSOLUTELY
DECISIVE.
AND, AGAIN, PART OF MY
DISCUSSION WITH MR. EASTMAN WAS,
IF YOU WERE RIGHT, DON'T YOU
THINK AL GORE WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO HAVE KNOWN IN 2000 THAT HE
HAD AUTHORITY TO JUST DECLARE
HIMSELF PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES?
DID YOU THINK THAT THE DEMOCRAT
LAWYERS JUST DIDN'T THINK OF
THIS VERY OBVIOUS QUIRK THAT HE
COULD USE TO DO THAT?
AND OF COURSE HE ACKNOWLEDGED,
AL GORE DID NOT AND SHOULD NOT
HAVE HAD THAT AUTHORITY AT THAT
POINT IN TIME.
>> SO, A RESPECTED JUDGE AND
LEGAL SCHOLAR KNEW THE EASTMAN
THEORY WAS BOGUS.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S OWN LAWYERS
KNEW IT WAS BOGUS.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S GENERAL
COUNSEL, GREG JACOB, TOLD
EASTMAN IT WAS BOGUS.
AND THERE'S TESTIMONY THAT
EASTMAN HIMSELF ADMITTED THE
CHALLENGE WOULD GO DOWN IF
CHALLENGED IN THE SUPREME COURT.
>> WE HAD AN EXTENDED DISCUSSION
AN HOUR AND A HALF TO TWO HOURS
ON JANUARY 5th.
AND WHEN I PRESSED HIM ON THE
POINT, I SAID, JOHN, IF THE VICE
PRESIDENT DID WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
HIM TO DO, WE WOULD LOSE 9-0 IN
THE SUPREME COURT, WOULDN'T WE?
AND HE INITIALLY STARTED, WELL,
I THINK MAYBE YOU WOULD LOSE
7-2.
AND AFTER SOME FURTHER
DISCUSSION ACKNOWLEDGED, WELL,
YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE WOULD LOSE 9-0.
>> SO, IF THIS TESTIMONY IS
ACCURATE, IT MEANS THAT DESPITE
ADMITTING THAT HIS PLAN WAS
UNPRECEDENTED, INADVISABLE IF
THE OTHER SIDE DID IT AND ALMOST
CERTAINLY LEGALLY INDEFENSIBLE,
HE PRESSED FORWARD ON JANUARY
6th.
SO DID RUDY GIULIANI.
SO DID THE FORMER PRESIDENT, WHO
ALSO IT WAS REVEALED TODAY MADE
ONE FINAL CALL TO HIS VICE
PRESIDENT ON THE MORNING OF THE
6th, ONE FINAL CALL TO PRESSURE
HIM AND ULTIMATELY INSULT HIM.
>> AND WHAT DID YOU HEAR?
>> SO, AS I WAS DROPPING OFF THE
NOTE, MY MEMORY, I REMEMBER
HEARING THE WORD "WIMP."
YOU KNOW, HE CALLED HIM A WIMP.
I DON'T REMEMBER IF HE SAID, YOU
ARE A WIMP.
YOU'LL BE A WIMP.
WIMP IS THE WORD I REMEMBER.
>> DID MRS. TRUMP SHARE ANY MORE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT HAD HAPPENED
IN THE OVAL OFFICE THAT MORNING?
>> THAT HER DAD HAD JUST HAD AN
UPSETTING CONVERSATION WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT, THIS
IS THE WORDINGS OF, I MADE THE
WRONG DECISION FOUR OR FIVE
YEARS AGO.
>> AND THE WORD YOU RELAYED THAT
THE PRESIDENT CALLED THE
PRESIDENT -- I APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING IMPOLITE.
BUT DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT SHE
SAID HER FATHER CALLED HIM.
>> THE P-WORD.
>> AND THEN A SHORT TIME LATER,
KNOWING THE MAN WAS IN HARM'S
WAY FROM AN ANGRY MOB FOR
REFUSING TO CARRY OUT A MAN HE'D
BEEN TOLD WAS WRONG, HE SENT OUT
A TWEET ATTACKING HIM, WHIPPING
TUP CROWD.
ACCORDING TO THE TESTIMONY
TODAY, HE HAD EVERY REASON TO
KNOW WHAT HE WAS DOING WAS
WRONG.
ACCORDING TO THE TESTIMONY
TODAY, SO DID THE PEOPLE PUSHING
JOHN EASTMAN'S PLAN TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION.
SO DID JOHN EASTMAN HIMSELF,
ACCORDING TO THE TESTIMONY
TODAY.
AS FOR WHAT JOHN EASTMAN DID
JANUARY 6th, THE SELECT
COMMITTEE SAID TODAY THEY HAD AN
EMAIL HE SENT TO RUDY GIULIANI